[Applause]
the legacy of you doing shadow flow
right because it's obviously
we're on five now right now i'm through
i'm through yeah and it was dead
but now there's top shot of flow right
mm-hmm no wait what was
that there's another one that that's on
the album though
yeah talk about that um
what i think is dope is unlike most
people who are in your uh
lane or your peers rather in hip-hop
right now like you you make it an
emphasis
and a point to make sure you're like a
dope rapper
no but you're you're like you're you
know like
there's some of this new [ __ ] i just
can't listen to because it's it's i
i don't know if it's because i'm an old
head or but i appreciate
people who actually rap and you're
actually like a dope rapper
so like what what uh when you were
growing up
growing you still growing up but like
what was what was some of the
more lyrical rap [ __ ] that like kind of
influenced you to um
you know kind of put more of an emphasis
on the on on the on the bars and making
sure you ain't like you know
my pops like he's just stay bumping um
tupac
and ugk and um m c button b all that
yeah
oh it is so it was really the music i
grew up off of and chief keith
all this stuff so you get a mix about it
i just feel like
the gangsters get especially ugk audio
if there was one og that you haven't
worked with yet who's like the og that
would be like your like
bucket list feature like if you could
work with somebody obviously somebody
who's still alive like who would that be
um
i really was why ain't really wayne
wayne just they go back to the shutter
flow thing
yeah i see it that's the only way i make
another shadow flow with is if i want
six dual six yeah great have you had any
communication with wayne or i mean i'm
sure he knows who you are
not they said he'll be on oh no i think
he'd be distant from a lot of [ __ ]
that is true and he's like in love now
yeah so i'd just be cool
[ __ ] so wayne is the guy who'll get you
to do another shot of flow
hey wayne the tick on the shutter flow
you ain't i want to hear
you've mentioned ugk which is one of my
favorite raglers i feel like you and bun
b would do uh
have you ever heard the ugk record
murderer i don't think so
listen man if you remade that record
i'ma play it for you before you leave
i probably have possibly probably played
it i know diamonds and wolves
if you did like a 20 20 version of that
it's in your bag bro and put bun
on it and you feel like yeah of course
um yeah that'd be crazy though wayne
yeah we got to make that let's put that
into the world man we gotta do that
put that shot of flow six that's the
only way shout out for six
weezy yeah